[Applaudissements]
soit je vais vous parler d'un secteur
d'activité c'est le siècle
la production a pas de sens si l'anc de
choses on sait l'aquaculture en faire de
l'agriculture mais plutôt un film c'est
tellement anecdotique des dogons père
qui est dans le camp des députés défaits
en championnat et autant vous dire à
cette époque de l'année c'est également
que j'apprécie beaucoup
depuis ces dernières années et j'en suis
arrivée là parce qu'à un moment je
persiste on en produit dans la
production animale c'est moi l'exemple
c'est le tour on fait le monde
utilisation des gros clowns on détruit
on également
on détruit la nature donc par rapport à
ça je pars disait quelque chose et je me
suis penché sur le sujet ce soit je
voulais partager avec vous challenge les
médecins c'est de changer notre façon de
produire le monde de production
actuellement nous sommes en production
lignières et diamants consignations les
doigts en qu'elle est inconnue on va le
consoler et ont valu jeudi
tout le monde le fait c'est pas vous
même vous le faites moi je me réjouis
on va faire une grosse pour acheter
quelque chose on va le consoler donc si
on mange pas 12 jan
on va lui jette aussi surtout n'ont pas
l'âge que j'ai acheté comme un lâche et
souvent en plastique d'emballage on va
pas les combats parfois si ça devient
vite la production lumière elle produit
vaut ses impacts sur la biodiversité et
européennes de salive
en fait vous faire ça ce n'est pas une
solution et essayez aussi libolo parce
que la solution elle existe déjà et les
dans la nature
il suffit de copier la nature comment la
nature elle fait la nature ne connaît
pas du production linéaire elle force on
vous dit sensible est la vie de nos
acteurs les acteurs y vivent acteur
vivant il va être complémentaires un
atelier vendent un produit un événement
qui va servir à notre ville celui même
va aussi plongé d'un élément qui va
servir et à nantes est vivant il y avait
différents acteurs qu'on arrive à fait
une inconnue sensible la production
cyclique
ça n'existe pas les niches et on les
valorise on avoir commis ce que nous
faisons on ne reproduit on utilise le
droit actuel vivre on va utiliser une
croissance
les tenantes est parti ce qui est ni
comique vous fait une définition simple
de laponie en imaginez vous bien c'est
la polyculture c'est le mariage de
l'aquaculture qui élit drones les
fonctionnaires on va utiliser les
déchets des boissons une culture
comment ça marche exactement en unis les
poissons avec un aliment qui doivent
être riche
ces points sont là vont générer des
déchets organiques les plantes non pas
qu'on voit manger directement ses
déchets ces déchets organiques doivent
être transformé l'essai ce deuxième
acteur qui était intéressant le monde
invisible à nos débats critiques elles
vont transformer ces déchets là il ya
une bonne et longue assimilable par les
plantes donc une belle plante avant
pleine bulle et les musulmans de l'eau
elles vont enlever ces nutriments qui
peuvent être toxiques pour les boissons
elle maintient la qualité de l'accueil
vivre ensemble complémentaire
il ya une diversité de plan que nous
pourrons faire en accueillir une
diversité de poissons également
quand on sait la production le cycle
primaire en futur végétale en les
logeant chez beaucoup de notre culture
de notre challenge que nous avons c'est
l'utilisation des pesticides les
pesticides
vous les connaissez tout ça fait un
petit peu peur en veut à tout prix
consommer des produits sans pesticides
d ici 10 ans à allier il ya des
fongicides insecticides si vous voulez
témoigner les insectes
iliad interdit si c'est du jeu les
pesticides ces thèmes et nos jeux nous
le savons tous un parc du suivi du
rendement a pas tous issus à santé
humaine
un sujet d'actualité plus haut certains
documents doivent connaître l'amour menu
qui faisait cette édition 2011 à 2 ce
qui est intéressant dans l'exemple du
diffuseur
c'est que c'est la même chose pour tous
les produits venant qu'en l'utilisant
production il fonctionne appliquée de la
même façon le glyphosate rester dans les
sols il un fort vent dans les saules
volatile et systémique sa dirigeante
dans la plante va se retrouver dans les
tissus de la peau un animal mort
j'imagine si l'alimentation pour lancer
ces problèmes sur la santé humaine
spécialement ceux qui vont appliquer le
glyphosate
enfin depuis l'élimination c'est le plus
exposé je suis la voix est si fortement
qu'on sait déjà où je suis passé de
pesticides refait de l'agriculture
conventionnelle
oui la solution si elle existe la
solution c'est notamment la permaculture
et youtube elle m'a offert ma culture on
va donner d'activation et la concurrence
y est tout est une toute petite cour de
ce que la permaculture fait on a
retrouvé au fil des lavages
on utilise les déchets organiques issus
d'élevages conseils de culture
donc pour lutter contre le ca il est
géré un peu qu'ils n'entrent le
production on va utiliser de choses on
va faire on va favoriser la diversité et
moi celle qu'on va favoriser la
prévention aux nîmois de la divette et
vous savez brûlent nos jours on vit
beaucoup
culture une seule variété végétale ceux
des grandes surfaces
qu'est ce que ça fait ça en fait faut
savoir d'un végétal c'est ce que l
insecte mange en hiver et un accès il
est aux anges quand on fait de la
monoculture la secte qui est spécialisée
pourrait avoir de cette culture
elle m'a vu les meilleurs ma seule au
combat ville ça va bien un dialogue
martèle qu'on sera obligé de pulvériser
d'utiliser ces par les pesticides
parsemer son instinct pour il faut
diversifier
on se dit qu'on fait beaucoup de
polyculture on va avoir une succession
de plusieurs balles et est végétale que
quand on fait ça l'imaginaire humain qu
en un siècle qu'est ce que ça vous
écoutez rythmes variés ils vont tous
arrivés selon boullier sa promesse qui
fois fascinante même delà la diversité
des futurs votre photo à droite en
exploitation nouveau centre près de la
centrale
encore une fleur en dari mais nous
allons être en fleuret ça arrive de 1,5
il ya des bancs insectes on avait les
occidentaux ont aussi la menace d'une
coccinelle qui dévore le puissant à
coccinelles séparé qui des vols plus les
bus enseignement sarnez donc que quand
tu as une diversité d'insectes les
insecticides
ils vont ils étaient 2000 juste d'être
années qui viennent beaucoup aussi de
prévention
le mailloux rhône upe les venir que du
cuir dans les motifs ou fait une
pulvérisation foliaire pas
révolutionnaire pour utiliser vos de
nature nous faisons beaucoup de matière
à son plan en sélection on fait des
macérations boulot on les coqueluches où
ils ont fait des bulles des libations
premières pour protéger leur amour on
utilise le mot savonneuse
nous avons deux ans qu'on résiste aux
formes progressèrent les insectes
appartement sans lui je vais faire c'est
l'une essentiel de l'eau douce qui est
facile à utiliser un insecticide naturel
où on fait beaucoup sur le préventif on
va vérifier une fois par semaine minimum
et on peut l espace et une fois doublé
de semaine le maintenant à côté ces
plans de dévaluer le débat d 1,5 et de
réagir en conséquence
dimitri
et dénis challenge beaucoup plus d'ordre
général on doit nourrir la planète
le secteur privé n'a donc jamais culture
le challenge qui se présente à moi en
général il ya des chaînes mondiales
estime finnois d'un produit beaucoup
n'ont pas beaucoup d'espacé ça change
l'art promis à plein désert qu'on a déjà
pu essayer un design cause de la petite
échelle en fait les bacs de culture par
une culture commune iv aller dans les
villages le substrat on sait venir la
solution nutritive directement dans les
bacs
ces débats et des cultures qui
fonctionnent comme des étables à mal le
niveau toiletter le débat qui va
constamment vaille pourra aider les
lacets des systèmes sympa pour se faire
la main en entrant à hauteur d'homme a
plutôt franchise goûter c'est normal
c'est ce que j'utilise beaucoup roulé à
petite échelle au niveau pierre
politique familles qui veulent en faire
une sorte de de vente
quand on verra les à vos yeux vraiment
plus on va se focaliser sur lot de type
de système donc on a travaillé aussi sur
system mirabeau flottant donc c'est une
piscine avec la solution de financement
du système a reconnu
on va faire flotter des plans sud et
arnaud ce seront des feuilles de
polystyrène il en arrive à avoir des
événements qui sont quand même
intéressant arrive à doubler le
lendemain on peut faire en plein champ
conventionnel
on va dire dans ce système de culture
dans les salades ma chute est bien tout
ce qui est prête à faire les armes à la
main
le marché libyen cela vous ne vous voyez
ces petits systèmes 25 mai dans le
domaine du maintien
on sortait quasiment par semaine sans
discontinuer on craint le plus les
notations les coups de hache et nous
correspond aux images tv offre de
systèmes ont travaillé sur notre système
que j'affectionne le plus s'appelle
athénée du sillon des minimes en danger
cités auraient utilisé des structures
hors sol on va faire couler en finn est
beau dans l'histoire
les plans de bambi kino puiser ce
qu'elles ont besoin dans la solution de
tweetie l'eau du système
donc on n'a plus les mêmes en leur
demandant ce type de système on arrive à
doubler en faire un peu plus
donc le système que vous avez vu
celui-là effet souvent c'est ce qui est
le plus utilisé à l'échelle commerciale
à l'échelle des lanternes et vidéos
qu'on peut encore produire davantage en
fait ce qu'on appelle des cultures et
ical
donc je lui même eu en vise au sol on va
essayer de cultiver plus donc on va
aller en hauteur
ça s'appelle culture éthique avons fini
nos comiques
là ça devient intéressant en termes de
lancements donc le challenge du collier
ou n'ont pas ou peu d espace on arrive à
faire deux fois plus en plus ici on
espère tellement options faire du fonds
russe ça devient vraiment intéressant
que nous évoquions la propriété mais
plusieurs choses
elle va permettre une production
circulaire on valorise ya plus de chiens
pas du pacifique chi minh ville et on
arrive à koudougou dans une espace il ya
quand même de la paix de recherche
développement je vois bien vu en un
système encore plus autonome adapté au
contexte de chaque archipel un porte
parole donnée ce soir s'est vainement
tenté de le voir du changé que nous
devons changer changer notre façon de
produire changer notre façon de
consommer et ces changements là c'est ce
qui va nous permettre de dessiner la
nouvelle agriculture ni de messi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]